so a couple of your older projects have
gotten new life I don't know if you know
this but we hear that there's a
potential Freaky Friday Sequel and
summer school is blowing up online like
did you expect that 35 years later that
is it's all blowing up like people are
wanting the sequel and now they're
talking about this again well uh the the
the first one is because Jamie's talking
about it yeah and you know Jamie yeah I
love Jamie right I do too and I've known
her since she was 15 so oh wow if she if
she's talking about it then it'll happen
it's probably going to happen because
all things happen yes very but it's did
you ever expect the other one though
summer BL like for 35 years later yeah
summer summer school sorry no uh I was
just so thrilled that Carl Riner was
interested in me to play this part and
and then my wife read the script at the
same time said don't Don't Go Near this
don't don't do this but we have very
different opinions of material and
things like that which is healthy but uh
I just said he thinks I can do this yeah
so I'm going to do it yeah I went and
did it I love that and all those
kidss but I love that it's like blowing
back back up I just think it's cool and
it comes back around it's like music
people like Mike I hear young kids
talking about music I'm like that's like
from the 70s like what yeah and and all
those people were young and just
starting out at that time right so so
those kids were all over 30 when they
were applying high school kids so of
course every one of them had an idea
after every saying hey Carl hey Carl hey
Carl can I do this and he'd go no no
stick to it yeah and but so many of the
little threads at the end of every scene
that he let the camera roll on are in
that film oh cool and I had a chance to
work with him later years laying down a
track for the for the the movie years
later yeah U and a chance to sit with
him for four hours and and do that and I
I loved that opportunity to finally tell
him what he meant to me oh that's so
cool yep yeah you like to tell people
that I like that about you so far in
this interiew you like to like let
people know that they've like made a
change in an impact in your life that's
cool I was telling you that on the way
out I well nobody not everybody does
that yeah why I don't know I don't know
maybe they feel foolish or whatever I do
I'm like well I'm a very chatty person
in general so I tell everybody
everything there's a there's a kindness
in that it's not just being a chatty
person yeah it makes me feel good to
tell someone that they've made a big
impact on me
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home